are you ready for some meatballs so now
this you know Australian company
resurrects flesh of a lost species to
demonstrate potential of meat grown from
cells we're gonna be growing meat in a
laboratory science meat
if you were a humanitarian or if you're
like a vegetarian a vegan if you're one
of these like animal rights activists I
think this is the way you'd want to go
so then the new vegan restaurant is
going to be like yeah you could get a
porterhouse steak in here laboratory
grown so then vegan is going to become
this new thing where it's not going to
be plant-based and all this stuff it
could be like really
healthier safer alternative option
that's better for the planet to make
meat from these cells I mean I don't
know what's your initial thoughts about
it guys